what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so continuing our coverage of DC rebirth
what I want to do here is I want to talk
about Aquaman rebirth issue number one
now the reason why I want to cover this
as a one-shot because it's basically
like a prologue through the first story
arc of the Aquaman rebirth publications
is because I want to test the waters
here no pun intended I wanted to test
the waters here and see how people
respond to Aquaman that's why I try to
make this title as clickbait be as
possible in order to basically draw in
as many views as possible the reason why
is because in the realm of superheroes
Aquaman really kind of has a bad rap he
really has a stigma about him and for
those he as you don't know this really
dates back to the original Super Friends
TV show you know Aquaman was depicted as
the guy who talked to fish and that was
really the killing blow you know that
was that was the dagger in the heart of
Aquaman from that point going forward he
was a superhero that was never really
taken seriously now it doesn't mean that
he was taking all that seriously before
that that show he was not really on the
same level as like Batman or Superman
but he was still considered to be a hero
in the traditional sense that is to say
fans still took him relatively seriously
for a comic book character the issue
with this is that after you know the
Superfriends show he just kind of became
an on running gag now DC did what they
could to really bolster him up and in
fact the Aquaman of the 1990s if you go
and you know talk to anybody who is who
was reading DC Comics back then they'll
tell you Aquaman in the 1990s was a
badass I mean he had the hook for the
hand he was hardcore he was pretty
brutal but people loved it because it
was a total opposite it was it was the
exact opposite of how people perceived
him as goofy and nonsensical the problem
with this was that it was difficult to
keep that story going on for any real
measure of time because different
writers had different views of his
character it was much the same way in
the new 52 when DC came back and they
did a total reboot of their other
publications with the exception of the
Green Lantern's
and a Batman Aquaman was one of the
characters who was rebooted and under
the writing of Geoff Johns the character
really received a deep focus in the
sense that Geoff Johns did not shy away
from the perception of Aquaman
as a guy who talked to fish and in fact
this was addressed within the first
issue I think when Aquaman was greeted
with a fan you know where someone who
knew who he was and he said you know the
fans of aren't you the guy that talks to
fish and Aquaman said I don't talk to
fish you know it was something about
subtle manipulations whatever it is you
know at the same time it was also an
instance where by the question was if
you are the king of Atlantis and you are
standing up for you know basically the
the inhabitants of the oceans why are
you eating seafood and so these are the
kind of questions that Geoff Johns
addressed in the stories and it was done
very tastefully and it was done very
well the issue with this is that again
much like virtually any comic book
publication different writers have
different takes on the character and his
time progressed and Geoff Johns left the
title other writers picked up the title
and started changing things up to the
point where they didn't really care you
know a lot of fans that really care what
was going on and the Aquaman publication
began to slip in sales consistently now
something else to point out here is that
there is an extremely die-hard
Aquaman fan base and woe betide the poor
soul that walks up to them and says
Aquaman talks to fish you know it and I
know it they'll lose their the loser
Minds
they'll actually they'll absolutely
freak and that's natural in the realm of
comic books it with any kind of a
character or any team you're always
going to find the really really huge
fans who don't like people talking bad
about them simply because no one likes
it when somebody walks up to you and
says that what you like is dumb people
don't like that you know no one really
enjoys that and so one of the other
aspects here was the character of Meera
now Meera of course we know to be the
long-running wife of Aquaman but one of
the things that people that really split
the Aquaman audience base in in the new
52 was that instead of being a queen who
was loyal to Aquaman and loyal to
Atlantis but also strong and confident
and intelligent in the new 52 she was
basically depicted as being
short-tempered she'd lose her mind all
the time she'd freak out over everything
you know she had a really short kippur
with people it's not necessarily a bad
thing there are benefits to that the
problem is that it wasn't the Wonder was
of the mirror that people were used to
it wasn't the version that people liked
the most and this is the purpose of DC
rebirth the purpose of DC rebirth is to
drive fan engagement but also drive
sales when it comes to comic books you
drive sales through storytelling that's
really it people don't really care who
the hero is so long as the
is good that's one of the reasons why
Batman outsold Superman for such a long
amount of time because the stories were
so well written as opposed to the
Superman stories which were not very
well written at all it's also the reason
why the current run of Superman is so
good and selling so well because the
stories are so beautifully written with
Aquaman it's much the same way as long
as the stories are good people will buy
it so in terms of good storytelling
you'll draw in fans in terms of the
characters you'll keep existing fans and
that's the idea behind Dan Abnett
writing now something I'd also like you
to take note of here is that we're given
a kind of inner monologue here with
regards to the life of Aquaman and what
I really like about what Dan aDNA does
is he doesn't kick things off by
focusing on the surface and that's
really one of been like a big source of
contention for Aquaman we knew that he
you know was born from the surface we
knew that he discovered his history as
Aquaman being the the rightful king of
Atlantis
his mother hails from Atlantis we know
we knew that whole legacy about his
character but one of the big drawbacks
was that there was always so much
emphasis on Aquaman trying to adapt to
life in the surface with Aquaman as a
character you have to focus on the
oceans that's where his bread's buttered
that's where he hails from that's where
his the best aspect of his stories can
come from especially when it comes to
the villain of Black Manta and so the
idea here is that we basically return to
this Dan Abnett brings us back to the
oceans and says that just because
Aquaman is king of the oceans doesn't
mean that everything is perfect we
always knew that he had his own villains
in the oceans but with regards to this
situation here we're also being
refreshed where you're being brought
back to the idea of the deluge now if
those guys don't know the deluge is
basically kind of this this rebel
faction within the kingdom of Atlantis
with regards to Atlantis itself it very
much has a hierarchy like the surface
world you know for you know right wrong
or otherwise in our everyday lives we
have a hierarchy there's a hierarchy of
attraction there's a hierarchy of wealth
there's a hierarchy of intelligence it
starts at the very top with the wealthy
most you know most attractive or the
most intelligent people all the way down
to the bottom with those who are least
attractive least wealthy and least
intelligent with Atlantis it's much the
same way you have the royal family at
the top you have Aquaman you have his
wife you know but at the bottom you have
what's called the ninth level you have
people who basically refer to themselves
as bottom feeders now again Dan Anna
tells us this is not designed
be a slur term it's not designed to tear
them down it's simply what they are in
that society and those individuals
recognize that but in addition to this
the deluge basically recruits from those
individuals now the reason why Dan
Abnett gives us such a strong
understanding of this is that these
people who are at the the bottom of the
food chain so to speak in the realm of
Atlantis aren't cast out there aren't
they are people who are just kind of
trying to make their way they serve a
purpose but more so than that their
loyalty to Atlantis is of the utmost
that is to say their loyalty is is
almost rabid you know when it comes to
Aquaman when it comes to mera they
basically have to play dual roles you
know Aquaman has to play the role of the
surface dweller while also maintaining
his role as king of Atlantis he has to
fight alongside the Justice League he's
as much an ambassador to the surface as
he is a ruler of Atlantis you know he
basically represents Atlantis to the
surface world and he tries to maintain
ties or good ties between the surface
and Atlantis as best he can and for
those individuals at the bottom they
don't share this they basically say
Atlantis basically needs to maintain its
traditional pure tones we do not need to
have a king that goes to the servers our
king should swear absolute Failte to
Atlantis and should never swear fealty
to anything else you should have
absolute dedication to us you know and
should not delve into the surface world
more so than that you know these people
at the bottom basically view the surface
world as you know as pollution they view
the surface world as as a problem now
Dan Abbott tackles this on two fronts
when he says that they're basically a
pollution to the oceans it's done in two
ways the first is that people on the
surface don't really concern themselves
with what goes on in the oceans and
because of this they're doing no favors
to people who are in the oceans that's
the first thing the second thing is that
by virtue of the first people not caring
about the oceans are polluting the
oceans or throwing trash in the oceans
or you know there's radiation and so on
and so forth that goes into the oceans
and because of that the Atlantean
population does not look at the surface
world with favorable eyes now the other
half of this is that because Aquaman is
basically fighting against the deluge
trying to keep this this rebellion at
bay when Queen Mara is addressed by one
of the soldiers the question is also
should they bring in the
they're elite warriors you know should
they bring in the the drift now the
drift is basically like the super
advanced guard are these are the best of
the best when it comes to Atlantis of
soldiers the other part is bringing in
the entire army to wage war I guess to
take out the the full forces of the
deluge now the reason why Mira says this
should not be done is because the
surface would become aware of what's
going on and their focus may begin to
shift away from Aquaman being a super
hero to Aquaman being a problem you know
to aqua and being a hassle now Dan
Abnett doesn't say this directly but if
we were to read between the lines here
we could probably get away with making
the case that because Mira and Aquaman
are ambassadors ensuring the surface
world maintains a perception of Aquaman
is just as important as Aquaman acting
out that perception and so if this
conflict were to be word it were to
become known by the surface world it
would give off the indication that
Aquaman cannot control his own people
and the question is if Aquaman can't
control his own Kingdom what hope does
he have being an effective superhero on
earth and so public sentiment will begin
to shift away from support for Aquaman
and begin to basically move towards the
idea that he's an incompetent superhero
now this is basically kind of like Dan
aDNA tapping into the the run of Geoff
Johns not directly it's more or less
like an indirect kind of reference to it
in the sense of Geoff Johns dealt very
heavily with the idea of Aquaman being
perceived as in an epic superhero that
his powers weren't that great he was a
guy that talked to fish you know people
didn't take him seriously the idea is to
avoid that perception from coming true
now we know by virtue of going to this
comic that Aquaman is pretty badass in
terms of the things that he's capable of
in terms of strength his might his
dedication to Atlantis while also trying
to maintain ties to the surface world
but one of the other things that Edmund
also does too is he shows both sides of
the perspectives of Aquaman it's only
for an instance it's not for a huge deal
but there are a couple of fans who are
basically looking at the cover of Time
magazine which depicts Aquaman Wonder
Woman and Superman standing together one
of the fans says that Aquaman is
extremely hot the other one says that
she doesn't care about a superhero the
talks to a seafood platter this
basically represents the fan base where
this represents the reader base of DC it
represents those of you guys out there
who will always say but Aquaman just
talks to fish he's just superhero the
stalks of fish that's all he
but it also represents the fan basis
says no he doesn't he is a legitimate
superhero it's just they don't grasp how
awesome Aquaman is you know but the fact
remains here that without man holding
his own against the deluge this is
basically just an argument this is a
this is a depiction by Dan Abnett
telling us this is where things stand
yes Aquaman defeated the deluge you're
the leader of the deluge yes Aquaman's
able to hold his own yes Aquaman is a
formidable hero but it's a damage
telling us that the stories of Aquaman
are not just about him being a superhero
on the surface fighting alongside the
Justice League and being misunderstood
by society that the kingdom of Atlantis
has its own problems it has its own
issues there's a lot of things to cope
with there's a lot of things to handle
that being a king is not the easiest
thing in the world and so as this story
begins to wrap up what we learned is
this entire exposition this entire
monologue as it's been given to us is
basically coming from Black Manta and
what he does is he says that Aquaman is
effectively a killer Aquaman is a
murderer and this is basically Dan
Abbott telling us this is the route
behind why it is the Black Manta is
going to go forward as a villain of
Aquaman and why it is that he considers
himself Aquaman's main enemy now if you
guys are interested in learning more
about this if you guys want to know more
about why it is a Black Manta is such a
foe make sure you guys drop a like make
sure you guys get the sub button to
become part of the Rob core and I post
comment down below you know let me know
what you guys think about all this you
know let me know what you guys feelings
are because you know I really enjoy what
Dan admin is doing with Aquaman right
now I feel like following the writing of
Geoff Johns this kind of storytelling
was much needed for Aquaman's character
and I feel like it's a great step
towards reinvigorating him for the DC
rebirth line of comics going into the
future in terms of moving it away from
the guy that just talks to fish really
showing us what kind of superhero
Aquaman really is but we have being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and yeah I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]